OWEN WITH KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS,
AND DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
LAST NIGHT, PRESIDENT TRUMP
RELEASED HIS FAKE NEWS AWARDS.
IT’S LIKE THE OSCARS WITHOUT THE
MOLESTERS.
PAUL KRUGMAN WON BIG.
THE STOCK MARKET GAINED 40%
SINCE THEN.
TRUMP NOT ONLY HELD KRUGMAN
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HIS IDIOCY.
HE RETURNS THE REVIEW INTO A
MUCH ANTICIPATED EVENT WHICH IS
GREAT.
KRUGMAN ISN’T TREATED AMONG HIS
PEERS LIKE SOME ORACLE.
THERE WERE OTHER WINNERS BUT YOU
PROBABLY ALREADY KNOW THEM.
THE PRESS HAD TO COVER IT.
IT’S GENIUS.
THE TRUMP THAT THE MEDIA TO
COVER THEIR OWN SCREW UPS.
IT’S A GOOD THING.
THE MEDIA GETS STORIES WRONG,
NOT BECAUSE THEY LIVE UP BY
RUSHING TO JUDGMENT.
THEY ADJUST STATS IN ORDER TO
FIT THEIR BIASES.
IF THE SQUARE PEG DOESN’T FIT
THE ROUND HOLE, SIMPLY SHAVE OFF
THE EDGES.
TAKE TRUMP’S SO-CALLED ATTACK ON
THE PRESS AND THE FLAKY
FOLLOWED.
THEY SAY HE CALLED THE PRESS THE
ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE, BUT IF YOU
LOOK AROUND, HE WAS ACTUALLY
SAYING FIGURE NEWS.
BY CONFLATING FAKE NEWS WITH THE
WHOLE PRESS, THAT CRITICIZING
THEIR ERRORS WAS CRITICIZING ALL
OF THEM, IT’S ACTUALLY THE MEDIA
SMEARING THE MEDIA.
THEY DO THIS WITH EVERYTHING,
INCLUDING TERROR.
IF YOU CRITICIZE RADICAL ISLAM,
THE MEDIA CALLS YOU
ISLAMAPHOBIC.
THEY CLAIM THAT YOU ARE KNOCKING
THE WHOLE RELIGION.
LIKEWISE, POINT OUT THE MISTAKES
THE PRESS MAKES AND YOU ARE
KNOCKING A WHOLE RELIGION TOO.
IT’S A SHAME.
WE COULD ALL USE HEALTHY
CRITICISM.
THE MEDIA SHOULD BE THANKING
TRUMP.
HE IS MAKING THEM GREAT AGAIN
WHETHER THEY LIKE IT OR NOT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, KIMBERLY.
>> Kimberly: WHAT, GREG?
>> Greg: HE ROLLED THIS OUT.
>> Kimberly: SORRY, CLIVE.
>> Greg: HE ROLLED IT OUT
AFTER THE PHYSICAL.
AFTER THE PRESS WENT NUTS ABOUT
THE PHYSICAL, HE GAVE THEM THEIR
PHYSICAL AND HE MADE PEOPLE WAIT
FOR IT.
IT WAS LIKE WHEN HE TWEETED,
EVERYBODY GOES CRAZY AND IT’S
TRENDING.
PERFECT SHOWMAN KIND OF THING.
>> Kimberly: I THINK IT FELT
MORE LIKE A COLONOSCOPY.
BIG WINNER.
THIS IS PRESIDENT TRUMP OWNING
IT, SAYING THIS IS WHAT I HAVE
BEEN SAYING ABOUT THE PRESS AND
I’M GOING TO MOCK THEM AND HAVE
FUN.
IT’S CONSISTENT WITH HIS
PERSONALITY, THE WAY HE DOES
THINGS.
PEOPLE ENJOYED IT.
WHAT HE DID CRASH THEIR WEBSITE,
SIMILAR TO WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE OBAMACARE WEBSITE.
BOOM, IT’S DOWN.
>> Jesse: EXCEPT TRUMP DIDN’T
PAY $4 BILLION FOR THE SITE.
>> Kimberly: PEOPLE WERE
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS.
TAKE IT IN GOOD HUMOR.
FEELING GOOD ABOUT FOX NEWS
RIGHT NOW.
WE FARED WELL.
THIS IS PART OF HIS PERSONALITY.
>> Greg: THAT’S TRUE.
IT’S AMAZING HOW FOX NEWS DIDN’T
END UP ON THAT LIST.
>> Kimberly: AREN’T WE GREAT?
>> Greg: DAY NOW.
JUAN.
IN THE GREEN ROOM, YOU SAID I
THOUGHT IT WAS NICE OF YOU TO
SAY I’M GLAD WHERE WE HAVE THIS
TO SEE WHERE THE PRESS GOES
WRONG.
GOOD FOR TRUMP.
>> Juan: I AM SURE I SAID
THAT.
MORE FAKE NEWS.
>> Kimberly: IS THAT A
VENTRILOQUIST?
>> Greg: THEY WERE LEGITIMATE
ERRORS.
>> Juan: WHAT DOES THIS ADD UP
TO?
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
JIMMY KIMMEL SAID IT’S THE
STUPID PEOPLE’S CHOICE AWARDS.
NO, NO, NO.
LATE-NIGHT COMEDIANS ARE ON THIS
BECAUSE THEY WANTED IN ON IT.
THEY WANTED TO WIN.
STEPHEN COLBERT TOOK OUT THE AD,
BILLBOARD IN TIMES SQUARE.
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION,
MR. PRESIDENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, GOSH, THE PRESS
LOOKS SO GOOD.
THEY CORRECTED ALL THESE
MISTAKES.
THERE WERE RETRACTIONS.
PEOPLE GOT FIRED.
>> Greg: WHY DID THEY DO THAT?
PEOPLE WANT TO BE PROVEN WRONG
BY TRUMP?
THE PROVE WRONG TRUMP THEORY.
>> Juan: TRYING TO PROVE YOU
ARE RIGHT FOR YOU ARE SO WRONG
HERE.
IF A JOURNALIST MAKES A MISTAKE
AND OWNS UP TO IT, THAT’S BAD?
>> Kimberly: SUCH A SHAME
WATERFALL.
IT IS A SHAME WATERFALL.
>> Juan: I WILL TELL YOU A
SHAME WATERFALL.
2,000 LIVES IN ONE YEAR.
IS THAT A SHAME WATERFALL?
I HEAR ALL THE LIES.
>> Greg: DANA, I ONCE TRIED A
SHAME WATERFALL IN VEGAS.
TOOK ME HOURS TO GET IT OUT OF
MY CLOSE.
>> Jesse: THAT WASN’T WATER.
>> Kimberly: YOU JUST RUINED
RUINED --
>> Greg: I CAN’T NAME NAMES.
SHOULDN’T THE MEDIA TAKE THIS TO
HEART?
ISN’T TRUMP HELPING THEM?
>> Dana: JUDGING BY THEIR PAID
SUBSCRIPTIONS, YES.
EVERYBODY IS DOING BETTER AND I
THINK CHRIS WALLACE WHO GAVE A
REALLY GOOD SPEECH.
I CAN’T REMEMBER THE VENUE BUT
IT WAS ABOUT THE MEDIA AND
COVERING THE PRESIDENT.
IT LOOKED LIKE HE WAS REALLY
SYMPATHETIC WITH THE PRESS CORPS
AND THEN HE TURNED AND SAID ON
THE OTHER HAND, DON’T GET SO
PASSIONATE AND INVOLVED.
I WAS GOING TO SAY THERE WAS AN
EXAMPLE HERE, YES THIS ONE.
ZEKE MILLER OF "TIME" MAGAZINE,
HE GENUINELY FELT HORRIBLE ABOUT
GETTING IT WRONG THAT THE
REPORTING THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAD HAD THE BUST OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING JR. REMOVED
FROM THE OVAL OFFICE.
HE PAID A BIG PRICE FOR IT.
HE FELT SHAME.
HE APOLOGIZED.
HE CORRECTED IT.
IT WAS KIND OF A BUMMER HE GOT
LISTED ON HERE BECAUSE HE WAS
GENUINELY SORRY.
>> Greg: JESSE, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO COMMENT ON JIM ACOSTA’S
RESPONSE OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COMMENT OVERALL RIGHT NOW?
>> Jesse: I WILL DO BOTH.
>> Greg: JIM ACOSTA HAS
RESPONDED TO THE FAKE NEWS.
>> I -- HAVING BEEN CALLED FAKE
NEWS MYSELF, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IS THE KING OF
FAKE NEWS.
I DON’T WANT PEOPLE TO THINK I’M
SAYING THAT BECAUSE I HAVE AN AX
TO GRIND A RHYME IN CLINICAL
HAVEN’T ASKED GRIND, IT’S JUST A
FACT.
IT’S UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS SUNK TO THAT LEVEL
WERE ASKED TO GO AROUND ISSUING
THESE KINDS OF AWARDS.
IT’S JUST NOT -- IT’S JUST NOT
LIKE WHAT YOU WOULD THINK WOULD
HAPPEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Greg: THAT’S MY FAVORITE
PART.
IT WOULDN’T HAPPEN.
>> Jesse: I AM ONE THING TO
SAY: OUT.
HE GOT BOOTED FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE THE OTHER DAY.
HE WALKED AWAY IN SHAME.
IT’S FUNNY TO HEAR CNN TALK
ABOUT WHAT A FACT IS CONSIDERING
THEY GOT FOUR AWARDS, NOT FAKE
NEWS, VERY FAKE NEWS.
JUAN, I WAS DISAPPOINTED.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO GET
ONE.
I THOUGHT YOU GOT ROBBED.
I NOMINATED YOU FOR A FEW.
>> Kimberly: RECOUNT.
>> Juan: I HAD AN INSIDE VOICE
WORKING FOR ME.
STILL CAN’T.
>> Jesse: IT WAS BETWEEN YOU
AND SANJAY GUPTA.
IT >> Juan: I AM TELLING YOU.
WHERE IS THE MINORITY PRESENCE
ON THIS LIST?
>> Kimberly: OH, MY GOD.
NOW YOU’RE MAD YOU WANT TO BE ON
THERE.
>> Juan: HE DOESN’T KNOW, BUT
I AM NORWEGIAN.
>> Kimberly: I THOUGHT YOU
WERE PANAMANIAN.
>> Juan: BUILD A WALL,
KIMBERLY, WE NEED A WALL.
>> Kimberly: WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> Juan: YOU THINK IT’S GREAT
WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS KICKING
REPORTERS OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE?
>> Jesse: AFTER HE ANSWERED
THE QUESTION.
>> Juan: I KNOW SERIOUSNESS IS
SOMETHING YOU ARE ALLERGIC TO.
BUT IT’S TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE THAT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS BEHAVING LIKE
AN AUTOCRAT AND SAYING REPORTERS
ARE SCANDALOUS AND WRONG.
OUR PRESIDENT SHOULD BE BEHAVING
THIS WAY?
IT’S FINE FOR HIM.
>> Jesse: IT WASN’T A TIME FOR
QUESTIONS.
HE GAVE A 45 MINUTE BRIEFING TO
THESE REPORTERS WHEN HE WAS
WALKING ON THE SOUTH LAWN A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
WHAT MORE DO YOU WANT?
>> Juan: MAY BE A HELICOPTER.
>> Greg: TRUMP TREATS THE
MEDIA LIKE FLIES BUZZING AROUND
HIS EARS.
>> Dana: I THINK HE UTILIZES
HIS ACCESS TO THE MEDIA VERY
WELL, GIVEN THAT HE STARTED OUT
SAYING EVERYBODY COVERED THE
FAKE NEWS AWARDS.
MAY BE GOING INTO THE SECOND
YEAR OF THE PRESIDENCY, EVERYONE
CAN JUST HAVE A SENSE OF HUMOR,
RIGHT?
NOT OVERREACT.
YOU HAVE TO COVER THE THINGS
HE’S TWEETING BUT NOT OVERREACT.
>> Greg: DID ANY OF YOU SEE
WHAT "THE NEW YORK TIMES" DID
TODAY?
THEY PUBLISH LETTERS FROM
DONALD TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
IS THIS MEANT AS SOME KIND OF
OLIVE BRANCH TO SAY THESE OTHER
PEOPLE WE HAVE IGNORED FOR SO
LONG.
TO THINK THEY ARE SETTING IT UP
AND FOR THE NEXT DAY WHERE THEY
FIND TRUMP VOTERS WHO DON’T LIKE
TRUMP?
>> Kimberly: PERHAPS THAT IS
MORE MACHIAVELLIAN.
THEREFORE I LIKE IT.
BOTH SURPRISES, WHY NOT?
PERHAPS THE LATTER.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK IT’S
MORE LIKE A CARNIVAL ATTRACTION,
JUAN?
THESE FREAKS WHO VOTED FOR
TRUMP.
THEY PROBABLY DON’T -- THEY ARE
RUBES WHO DON’T KNOW WHAT
WHOLE FOODS IS.
>> Juan: IF THAT’S THE CASE,
THEY FAILED.
I THOUGHT THE LETTERS MADE THE
CASE PRETTY STRONGLY FOR WHY
PEOPLE FELT TRUMP WAS DOING A
GOOD JOB.
THESE ARE SMART PEOPLE.
I DON’T THINK YOU COULD DESCRIBE
THESE PEOPLE IN ANY WAY AS
DEPLORABLE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO MADE THE
CASE.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" GAVE THEM A
PLATFORM.
I’M GOING TO GO WITH GOODWILL
HERE AND SAY IT WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO SAY JOIN
THE DEBATE.
WE WANT TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE HAVE
A DIFFERENT POINT OF VIEW.
>> Kimberly: LET’S HOPE SO.
>> Jesse: I RESPECT THAT THE
TIMES DID THAT.
I THINK THE TAKEAWAYS FROM THE
LETTERS I SAW WERE THERE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS WERE WILLING TO CAST
ASIDE THE CHAOS AND THE BRASH
STYLE IF THE POLICIES WERE GOOD,
AND ALSO THE PRESS HATING TRUMP
ACTUALLY MAKES THE TRUMP VOTERS
LIKE TRUMP MORE.
>> Greg: I THINK THAT’S TRUE
WITH ME.
I MADE, IT HAS A DEFINITE EFFECT
ON ME, DANA.
WHEN I SAW THE ANTIPATHY GET SO
MUCH.
THIS CAN’T BE RIGHT, CAN’T BE
REAL.
YOU CAN DISLIKE SOMEBODY BUT TO
PAINT THEM AS HITLER AND INSANE,
YOU REALIZE SOMETHING IS WRONG.
>> Dana: I THINK
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DID IT WITH
ALL SINCERITY BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THAT THEY GENUINELY WANT
TO UNDERSTAND.
WHY WON’T PEOPLE --
YOU HEAR THAT.
I WAS ON THE UPPER EAST SIDE
LAST NIGHT AND YOU HEARD PEOPLE
SAY THEY DON’T UNDERSTAND.
ONE OF THE THINGS IS THAT IT
TALKS ABOUT THE VOTERS NOT HIM.
AND I THINK ALL THOSE LETTERS
WERE VERY, VERY GOOD.
IF YOU HAVEN’T READ THEM YET, GO
ON THE WEBSITE AND CHECK THEM
OUT.
IT WILL GIVE YOU -- IF YOU DON’T
LIKE THE PRESENT, YOU CAN READ
THOSE AND SAID I UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY DO.
>> Juan: THE ONE THING TO
CONSIDER THIS IS DON’T FORGET
THAT THE SAME WEEK YOU HAD
SENATOR FLAKE, JOHN McCAIN,
BOTH SAY THIS PRESIDENT IS
BEHAVING WITH REGARD TO THE
PERSONALLY THAT UNDERMINES
DEMOCRACY.
>> Greg: BUT FLAKE LIED.
HE SAID DONALD TRUMP SAID THE
PRESS IS A THREAT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE SAID FAKE MEDIA, THE FAKE
NEWS MEDIA.
THAT’S QUITE A DISTINCTION.
>> Dana: WELL, I THINK IN A
WAY -- I THINK FAKE NEWS WOULD
MEAN SOMETHING IS WRONG, LIKE IN
THE AWARDS.
BUT THEN THERE ARE THINGS THAT
ARE TRUE THAT SEEMS UNFAVORABLE